واهلا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه النافذه
للتحليل العسكري لمجريات حرب اسرائيل على
قطاع غزه وفيها نستضيف المحلل العسكري
اللواء فايز الدويري وسيكون معنا كذلك على
الخارطه التفاعليه الزميل محمود الكن
لمعرفه اخر التطورات اليوم على الارض تفضل
محمود نعم ليلى بامكاننا دراسه هذه
التطورات على الارض حسب اللون الاصفر الذي
يظهر على كامل خريطه قطاع غزه اللون الاز
هو المناطق العسكريه الاسرائيليه المغلقه
في غلاف غزه اللون الاصفر هو للمناورات
العسكريه المناورات اختلفت بهذه الطريقه
هنا تحديدا في شمال قطاع غزه خلال الايام
الماضيه تراجع للاليات العسكريه في شمال
القطاع لكن عمليه التكتيكات العسكريه تبدو
ومن خلال الاخبار والمصادر على الارض كذلك
بان محاولات التوغل تتم من جنوب قطاع غزه
من جنوب مدينه غزه باتجاه الشمال تل
الهواء وبالتالي محاوله الضغط باتجاه
الوسط اذا ما اقتربنا اليها اكثر سنشاهد
ما نتحدث عنه هنا العمليات العمليات
العسكريه كانت بهذه الطريقه معظم كان هناك
استهداف ل مروحيه بالقرب من حي الصناعه
باستخدام صواريخ سام سبعه اضافه الى
استهداف دبابات ميركافا
هنا ايضا في ذات المنطقه اي ان قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ت حااول الدفع
بالاتجاه من الجنوب ومن ثم الشمال ومحاوله
لتقدم الوسط هذا التكتيك كنا نشاهده عبر
الايام الماضيه لكن يبدو ان هناك تراجعا
للاليات الى الشريط الحدودي بالنسبه
للشمال حسب المصادر المحليه هذا بالنسبه
لثقل مركز العمليات في بالنسبه لمدينه
غزه هو كما ذكرنا في الجنوب الغربي ايضا
بالنسبه لجنوب قطاع غزه نتحدث هنا عن خان
يونس مركز ثقل العمليات هو في الغرب في
هذه النقطه
تحديدا كتائب القسام ذكرت بانها استهدفت
مجموعه من جنود الاحتلال بقذائف التي بي
جي المضاده للافراد ايضا كان هناك استهداف
باستخدام صواريخ الجراد في هذه النقطه
لماذا هذه النقطه هي نقطه ارتكاز ل
العمليه او مركز العمليات هنا سنشاهد كنا
قد نشرنا صور اقمار صناعيه حصلت عليها
الجزيره في الرابع من فبراير نشاهد هذا
الشريط باللون الغامق هو لمدينه خان يونس
الذي التقطته الاقمار الصناعيه نظره اقرب
الى غرب مدينه خان يونس هنا سنشاهد هذا
التمركز لذا المربع الاحمر هو لتمركز
للاليات نتحدث عن حوالي 25 اليه تقبع هنا
وهنا مخيم خان يونس نشاهد دمارا شديدا
وكبيرا تسويه لمربعات سكنيه بالكامل هذه
الاليات يبدو ان مركز
الثقل تتمركز هذه الاليات هنا وتحاول
الدفع بالاتجاه الوسط باتجاه مستشفى الامل
ناصر الى اخره وفي محاولات التوغل الى
مركز مدينه خان يونس التكتيكات العسكريه
في بدايه الحرب كانت تعتمد على مجموعه
كبيره من الاليات تتمركز في مواقع وسواتر
ترابيه ثم تقوم بالتحرك الى مناطق متقدمه
في هذه المراحل تختلف عدد اليات اقل
محاولات توغل سريعه استهداف لاهداف وعوده
وهذا ما سندرسه اكثر في التحليل العسكري
معكما ليلى واللواء فايز دويري شكرا جزيلا
محمود طبعا اليوم ال 123 لهذه الحرب لواء
فايز ومن المهم ايضا ان نتوقف عند النمط
القتالي في هذه المرحله
وتوزيع الجهود العسكريه من الجانبين في
الواقع يعني النقاط الساخنه توجد في مدينه
غزه شمال غرب مدينه غزه كما اشار محمود في
منطقه تل الهواء شيخ عجلين
و الرمال الجنوبي
والمربع الجامعات ومربع الجوازات وعلى
امتداد شارع النصر في تلك المنطقه نعم
لماذا علما انه تم اخلاء المنطقه
والخارطة كان تظهر عليه سابقا هذه هي
المنطقه العازله واللون الاصفر يمثل حركه
القوات وليس ثبات او تثبت هذه القوات يعني
حتى الخط الاصفر في اقصى الشمال والشرق
ليس بالضروره ان تكون متواجد الاليات لانه
هذه الاليات قسم
منها عاد الى خلف السياج ويدخل في حسب
الظروف اي اشرنا اكثر من مره بانه القوه
تاتي من وادي غزه وبالتالي تنعطف اتجاه تل
الهواء لماذا لان لان هناك بعض المعلومات
التي ترشحت من المواقع الاسرائيليه ومن
جيش
الاحتلال هناك ايماءات بانه يوجد قاده
رئيسيين في تلك المنطقه وتوجد عقده شبكه
انفاق رئيسيه تفضي الى انفاق القتال
وبالتالي هم يعني خلال الاربع ايام
الماضيه وقد تطول لمده 10 ايام قادمه
يحاولوا ان يبحثوا عن هذا الصيد السمين
كما يتم وصفه منهم على سبيل المثال قائد
لواء غزه يتوقع انه يدير العمليات من تلك
المنطقه اذا هذه دعينا نقول هي مؤثره في
المكان ومؤثره من حيث حجم الق حجم القوه
لكن تقريبا القوه
50% من ناحال مشا 50% من اللواء 401
وكلاهما يعود الى الفرقه
162 الان اذا ذهبنا جنوبا منطقه الوسط
منطقه المخيمات
انخفضت وتيره القتال بصوره كبيره جدا
وبالتالي لانه فشلت قوات جيش الاحتلال في
ان تدخل هذه المخيمات رغم انه على سبيل
المثال مخيم المغازيه او الزوايده صغير
جدا مساحته اقل من كيلومتر مربع لكن لم
يستطيعوا
وبالتالي تمركزت القوات على قرب السياج
وضمن وادي غزه وتقوم بعمليه مناورات
عسكريه تقدم وتراجع الى غير ذلك اذا ذهبنا
جنوب الى منطقه خانيونس
منطقه خانيونس يجب ان نفصل بين امرين
المنطقه الشرقيه التي تقع ال الشرق من
شارع صلاح الدين وهي تمثل الغالبيه من حيث
المساحه وهذه هذه المنطقه لها خصوصيتها
وبالتالي لم تستطع قوات جيش الاحتلال ان
تحقق انجازا كبيرا بها وبالتالي نرى
الخارطه ان معظمها لا توجد علما يوجد
عمليات قصف عمليات احزمه ناريه وعمليات
دخول وتراجع سريع لكن لا يوجد اي عمليات ت
كثر التركيز عن هذه الاحزمه الناريه في ما
يتعلق بمحيط رفح تحديدا الان الاحزمه
الناريه من من 48 ساعه يركزوا على
استخدامها ما بين خان يونس ورفح الاطراف
الشماليه لمدينه رفح لانه مدينه رفح لها
وضعيه وضعها الخاص يوجد فيها تقريبا 1 ونص
مليون نازح ومهجر وهي في النهايه تنتهي
على السياج مع جمهوريه مصر العربيه
وبالتالي اي يعني كثر الحديث عن محاوله
وذهاب مدير الشم بيت الى مصر وايجاد مخرج
وكثر الحديث ان مع بلينكن في هذا اليوم تم
بحث هذا الموضوع الاداره الامريكيه وضع
رفح معقد لماذا لانه اي مناوره عسكريه
ستكون على تماس مع الحدود المصريه هذه رقم
واحد ويوجد واح ونص مليون النازح في تلك
المنطقه اين سيذهبوا بالضبط هذا هو السؤال
المحوري وطب طبعا السيناريوهات الكثيره
التي تطرح بهذا الخصوص ولكن اذا سمحت
للواء فايز لنتابع
فيديو الذي كانت بثته كتائب القسام اليوم
تابع
معكم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم وما رميت اذ
رميتم الهاون ا يوجد
ثلاث اقيس من هذا 60 80 120 وطبعا تختلف
التاثير والفاعليه والمد بناء على القياس
يعني ال 120 تاثيره اكثر من 82 اكثر من
160 من ال 60 وبالتالي لكن ضمن القدرات
والامكانات المتاحه يتم توظيف كل ما هو
متاح
بايديهم بدانا نشاهد التنسيق ما بين سرايا
القدس ما بين القسام في عمليات مشتركه
خاصه في بعد استخدام الهون نعم والملاحظ
ايضا انه يعني في السابق كان كل طرف يعلن
من جانبه ثم يتم الحديث عن تنسيق ولكن
الان مباشره تعلب كتائب القسام بالتنسيق
مع سرايا القدس تم استهداف هذه خاصه في
منطقه خان يونس لماذا لانه قوات النخبه
لبقيه الفصائل تتواجد بصوره اقوى مما كانت
تتواجد فيه في شمال غزه او في منطقه الوسط
وبالتالي لواء
غزه مستوى التنسيق مع الفصير الاخرى ان
تمثل قوات النخبه من الجانبين يعني لابد
من من التنسيق من اجل ضبط ايقاع المعركه
واداره المعركه الدفاعيه والا سيحدث هناك
اشكالات قد تعود بالضرر على المخطط
الرئيسي لاداره المعركه يعني بمعنى اخر
هناك خليه تخطيط استراتيجي مشتركه من اجل
ان لا يكون هناك اي تعارض في في اداء
الواجب وطبعا هذا يزعج الطرف الاسرائيلي
بلا شك لانه يتطلع الى القضاء وانجاز شيء
على الارض كما قال نتنياهو خلال
اشهر وزير الدفاع كان اكثر تفاؤلا بالامس
قال معركه خان يونس ستحسم خلال اسبوع وهو
نفس الكلام اللي تحدثوا عن شمال غزه عن
القاطع الشمالي وبعد اسابيع من كلامه بانه
فككنا البنيه التنظيميه ها هو الان عاد
يقاتل في تلك المنطقه ثنه الان يتحدث عن
اشهر على العموم نتابع طبعا ما يجري بشكل
مباشر اولا باول واشكرك جزيلا لواء فز
دويري